lumière d'abord tout seul puis à 2
milliards
une femme au régime envoûtant et ruelles
la sel de mer est un filtre pouvoir
éblouissant qui ramène et puis rebelles
et prodigue à leur nuage crevier le crre
de mes racines
ça ne se raconte pas ça se ressent comme
un poème qui se donne non pas à lire
mais avoir deux femmes qui disent qu'ils
chantent et qui dansent leur vie
quotidienne et leur combat permanent qui
est aussi celui de leur île
un poème visuel dédié au chorégraphe
jean françois colombo décédé en haïti
justement en 1996
[Musique]
des images qui rappellent ses pas de
danse et la rigueur de son travail
les pieds dans la caraïbe et la tête
dans le tout le monde
[Musique]
grâce aux intérêts forme de poire hi
than statut de sable de la liberté des
rades de new york aux arv
sainte-catherine de montréal je grimpe
au baobab scabreux de kinshasa de
brazzaville et de brancards
[Musique]
allez